the US has strongly condemned recent
Syrian and Russian airstrikes that
killed civilians in Northwest Syria
Syrian and Russian forces have moved
into the north of the country following
the partial withdrawal there by the US
last month and the invasion by turkey
Charlie d'Agata is on the ground where
the situation remains highly volatile
they came with whatever weapons they
could find from sledgehammers in rocks
to shoes and bottles and stacks of eggs
Kurdish residents who have seen hundreds
of their people killed in the Turkish
onslaught were not about to let a
Turkish and Russians convoy pass through
without a scratch
but they're just as angry at America for
allowing the Turks to invade in the
first place in the crowd we found the
mother of Hebburn caliph the Kurdish
politician executed in cold blood on the
street by Pro Turkish gunmen she blames
the u.s. for the attack and refused to
speak with us an American news crew the
convoy came into view then took a sharp
right but protesters chased them down at
the next tone and unleashed their fury
with everything they had
well the Turkish and Russian convoy
tried to get around these Kurdish
protestors and as they did they were cut
off at this point that's where they were
pelted by stones and ant eggs
and bottles of oil we've seen a few
people that have been injured in that
demonstrators told us they made their
mark why did you come today I came here
to tell the Russian and Turkish invaders
not to patrol our land one woman told us
we live here it's not their land not
even that much one protester was killed
in that demonstration he jumped on a
vehicle slipped off and was run over but
it just reflects the outrage aimed at
what the currency as an occupying force
Dana Charlie thank you